- How long have you known
each other though? You both?
- Since I was 17 years old.
- Wait, 17?
- And I was five, and
I was five back then.
(audience laughs)
- No, wait, what's that story?
What do you mean 17 years old?
How did you meet?
- Well, I used to teach
dance and cheerleading camps,
and where we were teaching a lot,
I thought about an idea
to give the winners
who would win in competitions
the concerts that were in town,
and it just so happened to be Journey.
And I got all these cheerleaders
who won prizes and awards
to come to the show
and I took them backstage,
and we were all in our cheer gear,
and we met Randy as a bass player.
- Oh, that's so crazy.
(overlapping chatter)
- And I was wearing crazy outfits, Carls.
- You were wearing crazy outfits?
- Well, you had to at that time,
you know how the dog does it.
(audience laughs)
- Oh, I love you so much.
Well, wait, Paula, there's something else
that I found interesting, I
did not know until yesterday,
did Michael Bolton sing
lullabies when he babysat you?
- Yeah.
(Randy laughs)
- Well, yes.
I lived in a condominium,
and my oldest sister, Wendy,
was really good friends with Michael.
And his name was Michael
Boloton, that was his name,
and he was an aspiring
singer-songwriter from Connecticut.
And he used to come out in the summers
'cause he had his girlfriend,
who ended up being his
wife later on, Maureen,
and we were all together, and
I would be in my brown uniform
and no one wanted to babysit.
And we'd make Michael,
Michael would have to babysit,
but he was the worst babysitter
'cause all he cared about was music.
(audience laughs)
- That panned out though, didn't it?
(Kelly laughs)
- And then Paula and I connected again
because when Perry left the
band, when Journey broke up,
after the last two events
that I was on with them,
we did a record with Michael Bolton;
we did "Sittin' On The Dock Of The Bay"
and "When A Man Loves A Woman",
and I was in LA, and Paula and I
hung out with Michael
Bolton and Irene Cara.
God, Paula, we lived some life, yoh.
- Ain't that crazy? How
different the chapters?
You look at your life and almost
like chapters, it's insane,
like who comes in and out,
and who comes back around,
it's a crazy thing.